have you ever been scammed via like any
money
money scheme or something like that
because like i remember i remember like
the phone scams and stuff like that no
just like just like being scammed with
like transferring money and then you
never got it back with something like
that because i remember when i was uh
the only time
i've sent money that was just like i
just got completely scammed and i
rightly so got scammed because this was
when i was trying to buy a fake id when
i was when i was uh when i was underage
right well yeah i mean yeah i mean i
totally deserved it
i i absolutely deserved it but i cuz
like i remember you know back back when
you were uk teen you know the person who
had the fake id was the cool guy right
he was the king yeah he was the [ __ ]
king because he could he could buy the
drinks he you know he he could he could
buy the alcohol he whips out the
realistic looking fake id and it's not
just like the obviously like really
like obviously fake student id that yeah
from like five dollars on the
from from like some guy yeah yeah um so
so i was just like how did so i knew a
guy who had a fake id so i was like how
did you get it and he tells me this you
know really dodgy [ __ ] website and
i'm just like of course and i'm just
like am i desperate enough to uh carry
the risk of trying to purchase this id
he says that he was downloading tor
because this is
how because this is how i realized
because the
you couldn't pay by a card with this
website right yeah no no no this is this
is [ __ ] this is way before bitcoin uh
you have to transfer via western union
oh my god like literally anything with
that is a stack yeah
anything that uses i'm pretty sure
that's how western union makes money
yeah yeah which is which which is which
is why i asked right because i of i
obviously
because i had never heard of [ __ ]
western union yeah i was just like what
the [ __ ] is what city know about it from
scout yeah
now i do know about it from scouts yeah
um
and so because i tried i was like i
tried sending this like i was like how
do i send money via western union is
that a bank is that like some nigerian
bank or something like like i've never
heard of this before and like i i
threw buying this fake idea because at
that point i was a dumb kid and i was
stupid enough to just trust you you were
desperate i was stupid and desperate you
have to just try anything to get a fake
yeah so i was like sure i'll i'll try
this western union stuff maybe maybe it
will maybe it would have worked
and then i find out that you can only
sell like western union uh transfers at
not even banks but like certain corner
shops in the uk right it's not it's not
even anything official it's like the
most it's like the most dodgiest places
you can send money and these are the
only places you can send money and i'm
just like maybe it'll work out maybe a
workout
that's like the equivalent of being like
you can buy this with cash but we have
to meet in an alleyway somewhere yeah he
can't be on the open road i think i
would have preferred to meet someone in
the alleyway because at least there
would be like another person i could
communicate right how much was it how
much was it it's like 30 pounds
i mean that was a lot for me as a 16
year old kid yeah whatever right
uh like uh what was i'm saying more of
the story is don't buy fake id kids it's
not worth it yeah yeah and also it's not
worth because you didn't [ __ ] get it
yeah don't be stupid like the moment you
see western union as well turn around
like don't even bother with that [ __ ]
i know japan actually has like a lot of
scams because like you know how the
population here is very old right like
the majority of them so there's a lot of
like phone scams that happen yeah i've
heard about that and the most famous
like variety of phone scams is uh
they're called oreo
which means the me me scam
so basically how it works is a guy calls
up like an old you know granddad or a
grandfather who like they do back
research to see like do they have
grandchildren do they have a son or a
daughter and they call them up and they
go oh it's me it's me
like posing as their son or daughter
being like oh it's me it's me um i need
help you know can you get me like x
amount of money so forth and so many all
people fall for it
everyone's so you know yeah polite in
this country yeah right yeah it's it's
insane how much like my grandma almost
fell for it one time i remember like
when i was quite young um luckily she
didn't but yeah there was they asked for
like absurd amounts of money like you
know upwards of like hundreds and
thousands of dollars
jesus just be like yeah can you transfer
it like tomorrow i'm like desperately
need i just lost my job blah blah blah
all that kind of stuff every year dude
like all people i need 100 000 and he
lost my job yeah i lost my job i need
100 domino's pizza in japan i need a
hundred thousand dollars i need to buy
out all the domino stocks
i need one large domino's pizza from
japan hundred thousand a hundred
thousand dollars
there's also the uh i think uh actually
i remember i watched videos about people
who became homeless in japan
and apparently one of the scams that
makes people homeless a lot of the time
is guarantor scams so like people uh
ask uh
people to be like guarantors on their
rent and then they just run off oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then they they have
to pay the guarantor thing and they lose
a [ __ ] ton of money yeah most people
can't afford to pay double rent yeah
yeah which is uh the shitty thing isn't
it yeah not not to mention the key money
and
itself
that's just a scam everyone's agreed to
i think yeah i think so at what point
does it stop being a scam and does it
just tradition is the biggest scam of
all i just i just don't understand the
point of that just being like oh yes
here is an extra month worth of rent as
a thank you for letting this peasant
stay in your abode and it's like
i'm [ __ ] paying rent every month are
you not happy with the rent i'm already
paying you money to stay in your place
and you want to pay me extra money to be
thankful that i'm paying you money
why am i thankful enough for the rent
why should i be thankful to pay you
money so yeah you can have to pay one to
two months rent up front yeah depending
depending some places you don't have to
oh yeah this is not a deposit because
you don't have the deposits like
everyone always asks is it a deposit no
no there's a deposit yeah which like
comes back to you after you move out but
then there's key money which just does
not return
yes it's literally just like it's just a
bribe that's all it is
is to be like you're letting me stay
right it's illegal it's a legal bribe so
you'll let me stay right need some money
you know at least uh they don't in japan
they have to deal with like microsoft
scams and uh like the indian call
centers oh yeah sure oh my god can you
imagine that
well i think it's the reason we get them
so much because any people can speak
english
but i remember the moment indians can
start speaking japanese it's over yeah
yeah yeah it's right
it's like the moment where actual
companies move their call centers from
india to like literally any other
country yeah it's over but it's always
in india that's what makes it so hard
sometimes yeah everywhere you'd call in
the uk it was always an indian call
center especially was internet yeah the
amount of times i'd call up and i'm like
i don't even know if i'm talking to a
scam because this service is so [ __ ] you
could fool me no it's always like
internet and banking as well yeah right
that's always great to have the two big
things yeah that's always great to have
a dad who worked in it because i never
needed to call them just be like father
help me please help help me i know
you're not yeah when i when i first uh
uh worked with bukoka
um i was doing a promotion with them and
it was actually on one of my videos
where i prank called scammers oh yeah
and this is where i learned that they
don't have them in japan
because i'd made this video right where
i basically just called up scammers and
i just kept promoting book order to them
yeah i remember yeah just kept doing it
i kept doing it and then i would like do
a super cut of like the funniest moments
and they would get really pissed off
yeah and they would be like microsoft
and i would be like i would just start
playing the fly prices write music to
them and just start basically doing a
pitch
and just pissing them off yeah and then
whenever they block my number i'd make a
new number and i call them again yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so i filmed it and it
was great it was really funny bit it was
like two minutes long and it was great
of me and it was great promotion because
yeah you know yeah i mean that seriously
was doing really well it was literally
me just doing ad reads for two minutes
to
indian and call centers yeah yeah um and
uh yeah and then i sent it off to book
walker and i was like oh god they might
not like it oh and then they were like
yeah okay it looks uh looks good uh will
we get in trouble with microsoft for
doing this
and i was like the truth comes out
microsoft backing up scammers
because because when we called them up
yeah they were pretending to be
microsoft yeah yeah yeah yeah
like oh is microsoft okay with you doing
this
how did you harass their employees
do we need approval from mike or
something
i was like what
oh no no you know what this is right
like no
what it's like yeah it's like the scam
you know they they call you up until
your pc being broken they're like no way
that's a thing that's a thing was like
i think it was
actually
you know when you call up microsoft you
know what's going to answer but cortana
is going to answer you first oh yeah oh
exactly yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah but
it was fake but i was i had to make sure
oh yeah sorry it's even worse because
melee is american amelia millie should
have known this yeah yeah yeah
she needed written proof that it was a
scam
so excuse me can you give me approval
that you're being scammed you promise
you won't scare me i promise i weren't
scared
yeah that is true actually now that i
think about it we don't have anything
like that in japan to be honest all
right because think about it even if
meline says that she jokes saying proof
right
what's stopping a japanese company from
saying uh we're providing tech support
yeah they get their hanko stamp their
japanese governments they start calling
up people saying hi we're microsoft they
probably wouldn't get shut down for a
while probably not because even if the
report gets filed the japanese
government will take five [ __ ] years
to analyze
and decide and by then they'll be
[ __ ] dipped out yeah and then they'll
have ten new networks and companies
like gentlemen we are expanding
dave knows no hunger
who's watched anime